[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, so if you've been
following along series,
you've heard me talk about
Cloud DLP and all the ways
that it can help you
inspect your data
and de-identify it with a whole
bunch of different techniques.
We talked about the concepts,
and we saw some code.
But if you're wondering
what DLP looks
like from a pointy,
clicky perspective,
stick around for this
extended episode,
where I'll show you some DLP
functionality in the Google
Cloud Console.
[DOOR CLOSING AND LOCKING]
[MUSICAL CHORD]
So for this demonstration,
we're going to do a few things.
What we have is a GCS
bucket with few files.
I'm going to show you how to
create an inspect template
and then kick off an
inspection job that's
going to tell us
which files might
have some sensitive
information in them.
Then after that,
I'll show you how
to create a
de-identification template
and then use that to create
an identical data set
in BigQuery with
encryption applied
to some sensitive fields.
OK, so before we
start, let me just
show you real quick
what we're working with.
So I have a GCS
bucket, some data.
And in that bucket, we just
got some text files, CSV files.
Some of them have
sensitive values.
Some of them don't.
Like, for example,
we have sample_s10
has some phone numbers,
while s20 has names
and Social Security numbers.
So it's a mixed bag.
We've got full names.
We have social security numbers.
We've got phone numbers.
So what we're
going to start with
is a DLP inspection template.
Let's get rid of this guy.
So creating a template
here is pretty simple.
You go to the Data
Loss Prevention
page, Create Template.
And here, you'll choose
either an inspect template
or a de-identify template.
We'll go for inspect for now.
OK, let's call our
bucket_inspect template,
a bucket.
All right, hit Continue.
And now, here's
the part where we
choose what infotypes we
actually want to inspect for.
So I'm just going to go for--
since we saw that.
We saw Social Security numbers,
and let's add a phone number.
Boom, added, done.
And then here, we choose
the confidence threshold
or likelihood.
So it can go, again, it can
go from very unlikely to very
likely.
We'll just hit Possible,
right in the middle.
Hit Create.
Give that a second.
All right, so here is
our inspection template.
And here are the two infotypes
that we're looking for,
the likelihood right there.
So now that we
have that template,
we can go over here, back to
the Data Loss Prevention page,
and we can now create
a job or a job trigger.
All right.
So the cool thing
about DLP is that you
can make it inspect
on a schedule,
so we'll call this
our weekly_inspection.
And what are we
going to inspect?
It's going to be
Google Cloud Storage.
And you can see
that you can also
do BigQuery or Cloud Datastore.
All right, and we'll make our
bucket name sample_data_dlp.
All right, and here, if you
scroll down a little bit,
you can actually
choose to use sampling.
So we're not going to use
sampling for this example.
But if you have a
very large data set,
you might want to use sampling,
because the more files it scans
for, the longer that
job is going to take
and the more resources
it's going to take up.
And then when you do choose to
use sampling, you can always
adjust it here, whether you want
to sample 50% or 20% or 100%--
which wouldn't make
sense-- but 100%.
But for our purposes, we're
going to say no sampling.
Here, you can also
choose the files
that you want to limit
your inspection to.
We'll just leave it at All
for now, and hit Continue.
And now, we choose our template.
We only have one
template, so it's
going to autopopulate our other
stuff, the templates that we
have.
And there it is,
our bucket_inspect.
And here are the details.
Again, here are two infotypes
and the likelihood of possible.
So for each job, aside
from just a template,
you can also add
some infotypes here.
But again, the more
infotypes you look for,
the longer that job
is going to take.
So what I'm going to
do is just deselect
any additional infotypes,
so we have nothing.
We'll leave the likelihood,
again, as possible.
Hit Continue.
And now, here are the actions
that you want your job
to take after it's done.
So we're going click
here, save to BigQuery,
and I'll show you why that's
important in second, but--
All right, our
project, a-dlp-demo.
Our data set is bucket_inspect.
So I created these data sets
ahead of time in BigQuery.
So before you do
this, you'd want
to do that yourself,
create your own data
set and then also
an empty table.
Inspect.
And there are other
actions that you
can add to each job, like
Publish to Pub/Sub or Notify
by Email.
But for now, we'll
just go to a BigQuery.
Hit Continue.
And here, you can choose
when you want it to run.
So you can run daily, weekly,
or custom, so we'll keep it
at weekly.
Hit Continue.
And that's going to give us a
recap of our job configuration
in the JSON objects.
Scroll down past that.
We're going to hit Create,
and we're going to Confirm.
So now, it's creating
that trigger.
Since it's a weekly one,
it's not running yet.
So we just hit here, Run Now.
Boom, and they're running
trigger weekly inspection.
So an inspection job
could take some time,
and that depends basically
on how big your data set is
or how many infotypes you
specified in that template.
All right, so we must
see how that job went.
You want to go back to the
Data Loss Prevention page,
and under Inspect
Jobs, there it is.
Click that, and this is
pretty much a recap page
of how the job went.
So you'll see that
it found 52 findings.
52 findings were
found in your data.
And 44 of them were phone
numbers, and 8 of them
were Social Security numbers.
So there's not much
more information
on this page than that.
If you want more information
about each of the findings
that it made, you
want to see what
it threw out in to BigQuery.
So these are all the fields
associated with each finding
that it made in your data, so
I'll show you a quick query.
We're going to select
the file name, which
should be here, relative_path.
And we want to include--
what else-- info_type
and likelihood.
Hit Run, and there you go.
So it's not just the file
has sensitive values in it,
and it made an
entry in a database.
It actually made an entry for
each finding that it made.
So, for example, you'll
see that sample_s08 is here
a few times because it
has a few phone numbers.
And you have the
option of including
the actual value of
that data, but I didn't
enable that for this example.
But you can see how much
sensitive data a file
might have rather than
just whether or not
it does have that sensitive
information in it.
An inspection job is a great way
to find out if your data might
have any sensitive value in it.
Now, let's create a
de-identification template
and see what we
can do with that.
OK, so before we create a
de-identification template,
I just want to show you
something real quick.
Since we're going
to use tokenization
to de-identify information,
on their cryptographic keys,
I'll show you how
to create a key ring
that I named dlp_keyring and
a key that I named dlp_key.
And we're going to
use it in a second.
So let's jump back to
Data Loss Prevention.
Once again, we're going to
go up here, Create Template.
This time instead of
Inspect, De-identify.
We'll call this bucket_deid,
and this is our Bucket
deidentification template.
Great.
Hit Continue.
And here, we'll pick
a transformation rule.
And there are some
familiar faces in here.
We see redaction, replacement,
replace of infotype.
Down here are our three
tokenization methods.
We're going to choose
Cryptographic Deterministic
Token.
Down here, we're going to
paste in that key information,
the resource name as a path.
And here, it's going
to want a wrapped key,
so it's pretty
much going to want
a key that's been encrypted
by that encryption key.
And I'll show you how to
generate that real quick down
here.
I'll open up our
Cloud Shell terminal.
And we're going to set this
variable to openssl rand
-base64, 16 characters, boom.
And then here's what
that looks like, right?
So we're going to take that.
We'll take off any spaces.
And we're going to pipe that
into gcloud kms encrypt.
And then we're going
to give it our key ring
and our key information.
So location was global.
Key ring was dlp_keyring.
Our key, dlp_key.
And we're going to
specify plaintext-file,
which is actually going
to be the value that we
piped into this command.
And then we're going to specify
a ciphertext-file, which
is the output that we want
it to go to, so ciphertext.
Hit Enter.
And what we got now is a file
that has some cipher text.
So we can't paste that in here,
so let's encode it to base 64--
hold on, let's clear that up--
base64, no wrapping,
and ciphertext.
All right, so let's
take this guy,
carefully select it, put it on
a clipboard, paste it over here,
and boom, there it is.
All right, so let's
get rid of this
and continue on
with the template.
So with Surrogate InfoType,
again, this the value that's
going to prepend in front
of the encrypted values.
So since we're only going
to look for Social Security
numbers, I'll just
make it SSN, and we'
going to specify the
infotype down here.
Manage InfoTypes, OK, there it
is, US Social Security number.
And again, you can
choose up to 150.
But for now, Social
Security number is fine.
And we'll hit Create.
So the cool thing about
the deID templates,
you can go over here to test it
out to make sure everything's
cool, everything's working.
So a Social Security number
is three digits, two digits,
and four digits.
And that is an
example of what it's
going to look like
when it's transformed,
and there's our surrogate
value right here.
So to demonstrate
de-identification
in action, what I'm going to
do is create a dataflow job,
which is going to take our
CSV files from our bucket
and then make a
de-identified version
of that same data in BigQuery.
So to create a dataflow
job, let's head over
here to the Navigation menu,
scroll down, Dataflow, Create
Job from Template.
So a job name, let's just call
it Bucket de-identification,
deID for short.
And under Dataflow
Template, we're
going to choose Data
Masking/Tokenization from Cloud
Storage to BigQuery
Using Cloud DLP.
And now, we must
specify that bucket
that I showed you earlier.
I have a sample_data_dlp,
and we want
to target the CSV files
that are in there.
So I don't know if
you noticed before,
but there was a
data set in BigQuery
that was called bucket_deid,
totally empty, no
tables or anything.
This will create
the tables for us.
And our project ID, dlp_demo.
And the template name,
which is on my clipboard,
temporary location is going
to be in the same bucket slash
temp.
Great.
All right, let's look this over.
So now what's happening
is that dataflow
is going through all of
those CSV files in our bucket
and then creating an
identical data set
in BigQuery with those
values de-identified
using tokenization.
So once the dataflow is
done doing its thing,
here is what it's going
to look like in BigQuery.
So here's our data
set, bucket_deid.
And now, in that
data set, there's
a table for each CSV file
that was in that bucket
that I showed you earlier.
So if you remember
before, we looked
at sample_s20 that had a bunch
of names and Social Security
numbers.
Let's query that table
and see what we get.
And boom, there it is.
Just like before, we've got
name, Social Security number,
and some other data.
But now, those Social
Security numbers
are completely unrecognizable,
because they've
been encrypted with
the key that we
specified in the
de-identification template.
So now, this data
is essentially safe
to use for any analytic
workflows that might
exist in your organization.
And that's it.
That was just a
quick taste of what
cloud DLP is capable of doing.
But if you have your own stories
of how cloud DLP has helped
you secure your data, feel free
to share that in the comments
below.
Thanks for watching.
Until next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]